steve kaufman um geez a week from now
i'll be going to mexico quite excited
um i'm going to talk today about
what i call letting the language come to
you
and i'm going to explain what i mean by
that
um
today this morning i played hockey
i play old-timers hockey three times a
week monday and friday we have like a
pickup
situation uh we have a blue team and a
gold team and uh
one of our members makes up a lineup and
we go there and we find out whether blue
or gold 10 on each side plus two
goaltenders
and we just play non-stop no whistles
and then on on wednesday we have a game
with referees and three periods and the
rest of it
uh this morning
our lineup we were the blues
we uh had a few nice goals my line in
particular we had a few nice combination
plays and goals and we i think we might
have won that 4-2 or something
uh and then in the second game we kind
of pressed too hard and uh tried to make
we were i think we were just trying
harder and and so we lost
and so my uh my winger there i play
center my winger said you know sometimes
uh we got to just let the game come to
us
rather than forcing it too hard and that
made me think of of my experience with
language learning
and
you know here i am now trying to juggle
three languages
i'm trying to continue to improve in
russian and check
and while at the same time
learn korean and there's only so many
hours in the day
so i find that more and more i'm just
comfortable doing
what i like doing and just accepting
whatever it is i'm able to achieve
so
of course to me the
the main thing that i'm able to do here
is to is to read and listen
and so my main satisfaction and sense of
achievement comes from
understanding so i spend a fair amount
of time at at link i i copy paste or
import items from
echo muskvie or from yaktovidii i listen
to them and then i go through them at
link and typically it'll have five six
seven percent unknown words and i'll go
through those and uh and then maybe read
it again
um and then i'll try to find time to do
some korean and there again in my korean
mostly i go at um more difficult content
like this uh kim hyun hee
uh
biography of this uh north korean uh
terrorists really who blew up a plane in
1987 and who's telling her life story
and and there typically the new word
count is like 40 so it's hard work
and then i don't understand when i'm
listening
but
you know ever since you know um and then
i have a discussion and sometimes i do
well sometimes it wouldn't do well and i
i found even with korea and i was
putting pressure on myself because
i couldn't understand what the uh what
the tutor was saying very well
unless
unless i
dictate the subject by talking about
something that i can talk about and then
of course the tutor has to come back
with something that i can talk about so
then we can talk about some limited
number of things but if if the tutor
starts going in korean
then i don't know what she's talking
about or he
and so that kind of bothered me in a way
and then i kind of said well like does
it really matter
um
just enjoy what you're able to do you
know just
um work my way through those difficult
texts i'm learning about
this korean spy and she's describing her
life in north korea and how she got
involved in this uh
in these spy activities or these uh
really terrorist activities occasionally
flip back to some easier content bang
bang's diary which we have
um but in czech and russian i'm i'm very
much still enjoying what i'm doing and
and it's funny like the last few times
that i've spoken with my russian and
czech and even korean tutors they've all
told me that i'm doing
better than ever
now
that of course depends on the occasion
if i've just come off doing a lot of
reading and i find that reading
especially helps if i've come off doing
a lot of reading i'll tend to do better
but today i've been listening to check
in the car and then i went to have a
haircut and my barber is ukrainian and
so we are usually speak russian and i
had more difficulty there
than i did when i had my conversation
with alex my uh one of my russian tutors
or with evgeny for that matter
so i guess i'm coming what i'm coming to
is like just as in hockey you know the
play comes at you in in a certain way
opportunities present themselves you
react to that
uh hopefully uh in hockey uh you know
the puck comes your way you're able to
see someone open uh you make a pass they
score or whatever
uh or you see a play developing at the
other end and so you'll peel back and be
ready to back check
when they counter attack and so you kind
of
feed off the play let the play come to
you rather than trying too hard rather
than going in and four checking like
crazy
uh and so in a in a way language is the
same way if you've had an opportunity
to speak a lot that you're going to
speak better
if what you are able to do is read and
listen
then uh do that and enjoy it and um when
the opportunity arises to speak more
you'll gradually start speaking better
uh i know with korean that i'm six
months away from i know that i have to
work my new words total on length down
from forty percent to ten percent
i know from experience that when i'm at
ten percent i'll be doing fine i'll be
able to express myself with mistakes but
i'll be able to express myself while i'm
at 40
i'm just gonna have to plow along so
that's that's how the game of korean
presents itself to me right now and so
because i have an unknown word count of
40
when i'm talking to my tutor they're
talking quickly i mean i can hear where
the words begin and end but i don't know
what they're saying
and so i just have to accept that that's
just the way it is that's the way the
the korean presents itself to me uh if
i've been focusing on check for the
30-40 minutes in the car listening to
something in check and all of a sudden i
have to speak russian
um to my uh ukrainian barber i'm gonna
struggle
uh that's just the way it happens that's
the you know it it doesn't bother me
uh and uh i i think part of it is that
you know i think a lot of people
of course everyone learning a language
wants to speak the goal is output
but i'm in no hurry
to be able to output in say korean
i know from experience that there will
come a point when i'll be able to output
better right now my ability to
make output to speak is limited and
that's fine that doesn't bother me
however it was interesting in my
conversation with stephen krashen
that he said that
that a lot of learners want this
transparency they want to be able to
understand everything they want to be
able to
speak when they want to speak
and so therefore i think that's one of
the reasons for the success
of programs like tprs which is teaching
proficiency through reading and
storytelling because there they make a
deliberate effort
to make people relax
uh
let them uh you know
create stories that are of interest to
them
and then they limit the amount of
vocabulary that's taught in any lesson
uh
they allow them the
students say time out if they didn't
understand
so that everything is done to relax the
student to make it relevant to the
student to make it of interest to the
student to make it only a limited amount
of vocabulary is introduced because this
then
makes the student feel more relaxed
it introduces this element of certainty
or transparency
however
and i think that's great for those
people who want to do that but my goal
is to get that new words percentage down
from forty percent to ten percent
uh in in reading authentic material like
this biography
so if every time i go to class i'm
introduced to three phrases only
it'll be a long time before i'll be able
to
read the
things of interest to me so for me the
way the game presents itself to me the
way the language comes to me the way
that i want to deal with the language is
that i'm quite happy just to plow along
reading and slowly increasing my
vocabulary slowly but faster than if i
were only learning three phrases per
lesson
because typically i'm i'm adding you
know
hundreds of words
hundreds and hundreds of words a week to
my vocabulary uh if i look at the
example of check
i mean i do believe that for me to be
reading czech articles where there's
only five percent new words but i
understand most of what's there
i have a large vocabulary it's got to be
in the 30 40 000 word
area i don't know that includes all the
inflections and conjugations and so
forth
uh and that's within 15 months so you
know that's several thousand a month
uh of words you can't do that if you get
learning uh three phrases
uh per lesson however
uh that's the way i want to deal with
the language that's the way the language
comes to me i accept it that way i
accepted the lack of transparency the
lack of certainty
the difficulty the inability to express
myself to say much of anything
uh for the first three four five months
stumbling
uh you know even in korean when i have
tried to
focus on these patterns and read them
and listen to just the patterns almost
out of context
in the hope that this would help me
in effect when i go to speak i don't
necessarily do any better
and rather it's when i've been exposed
to a lot of natural content
that i find i do better and so i'm sort
of able then to just rather than
forcing it forcing the study of certain
patterns i just take it as it comes to
me i'm doing things of interest that's
how the language comes to me
and i just keep plugging away so i don't
know if i'm making myself very clear in
this
but
we all have different goals in the
language
and we it gets back to again i was
listening to an interview on ekamuskvi
with
a
russian
gosh i can't remember his name was it
dmitry ivanov
who is a russian language teacher who
who actually had a
or petrov i can't remember he had a
program on russian television which i
saw where over a series of weeks or
months he taught people to speak english
and he was very effective and so he was
being interviewed
by
sergey buntmann on echamuskville
and much of what he said
i i fully fully agree with
and and one of the key things that that
he said that i fully fully agree with is
that the number one thing he said this
in answer to a question from a child who
phoned in but in ask when asked about
how what is the most important thing in
learning languages he said it's to enjoy
the process so you've got to enjoy the
process however whatever it takes for
you to enjoy the process
let the language come to you
enjoy it and you will succeed so i hope
this makes sense and i look forward to
your comments thank you for listening